I can't get it up here family should I
have notes too okay
what's a boom podcast was so full
podcast what's up fool
with your host Phillipe Esparza and I
need you right here
yeah man bald old up mid winter it's
cold out there dawg you got a new little
snazzy little sweatshirt you are
what's a fool podcasts where streams if
you want to get one we got as big as 4x
thank you and if you're bigger than that
you didn't have to go to another
comedians page 6 X 4 X these go to 3x
yeah
if now if a lot of guys want a 4 no well
no cinema screen huh if a lot of guys
wanna if enough guys want a 4 and I'm
saying guys cuz I ever met any 4 or 5 X
ladies the only time I've seen 5x and 6x
and it's a Corvette show those big-ass
Mexicans from Hayward Hayward and they
got the big sister - and she married to
a Samoan guy who does also buy wigs and
they had that long hair - they're huge
bro El Paso no no they're Sacramento
they were there there as tourists Marcel
argüello alright I would just say in
five Xers yeah the right I suppose too
bad but if enough guys nothin up guys
want one of these shirts you gonna be a
good in four or five X just email fans
at Felipe's Broadcom and I asked I'm
gonna be Chris D'Elia sauce Ball Z have
at least like 20 people interested in
that to make it worth printing a small
batches that's that bad because they're
gonna sit no but they're gonna sit in a
box which is what happened with all
those other four and five X's we used to
order for other shirts
these are I haven't put them on the
website yet but these are 40 again I
think yes here yes we do Rachel woof
woofs it hello
thanks for having me first time I heard
I thought her rule was that
laughs actually stream laughs act your
videos I wouldn't have a comics yeah
and that nobody other I don't watch a
ball you don't be the monologue the real
log and so they'll have like 765,000 by
the way the bottle but I guess I was
like to have Jim I saw that was my check
yeah that's a lot of fuse right well I I
got it one check you know probably laugh
at you for my when they switch to warm
the internet then I saw hers it was
[ __ ] hilarious dog yeah it was cool
bad like a lot of weed jokes but not
like I like we chose like the ones I
used to say they were real good was he
well she also runs the very popular
wolfy memes yeah on Instagram right yes
yes you guys like me tweed memes that's
it well that's funny they're funny you
make a lot of them but you share some
others right I share some people but
maybe it's mine yeah that's great
I mean she's like in a min stuff it
would you know a lot of her mean like
you know their original me maker yeah
means yeah my mom calls and Mimi's when
I first seen it I thought was me my mom
me me me me yeah little knees came up
but they're all means but the meme is
more of a meta concept it's more than
that the social popularity of something
anything it's like a digital joke yeah
yeah right and then I thought been short
joke no more like a bad digital
worldwide yeah something that goes viral
I guess sir you know everyone less
though hard left to watch people's
attention spans are very short that'll
be great for Mira you know what we're
gonna [ __ ] be right here but when they
want less sex
[Laughter]
I'll give you the best ten seconds of
your life I think they copy the wider
flowers and everything so what's up fool
bad oh yeah we get Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving was killer to do those
nursing right yeah last Thursday we did
a podcast Monday Thanksgiving was
Thursday yeah we're a base this weekend
Lola put the work for hon Wednesday okay
Thursday and then Friday we came home
that night because we did we want to get
back to the dog because we plan this
trip before we got the dog so we didn't
expect I didn't want to leave her with
will dump it on your old lady she has a
lot of ailments she didn't need
medication I was like I don't because
our assistant was staying with her and
house-sitting but we took the rabbits
with us I couldn't take the dog you guys
have a full house FSU and I didn't want
to transport her so soon after being out
of the shelter you know I wanted her to
feel like she's home she's like a big
kid yeah like should take me outside
like we're gonna go she didn't use the
restroom but she's standing outside a
car that you want to go a little right
he's got a little Pendleton please no no
no it's like fleece-lined right yeah
little flannel so you guys spent your
Thanksgiving at Morro Bay yeah I was in
Riverside at my mom's house funny
I will your brother it was dope I didn't
ruin it I wasn't a family member that
did it this year
someone did but it wasn't me I use a
coup cousin I let people look forward to
seed privately yes you know there are
some reason why they keep inviting me
back it's not because they love me it's
because they know I'm gonna bring the
greens because I saw be one time man and
it was that car it was like I was like a
[ __ ] cholo
let's get cholo a little irregular foot
standing next to them they're both high
because everybody has that couch all or
you could hang our thanksgiving get lawn
chair i always disappear bro thank you
thank you i get [ __ ] up though okay
bro we'll go to our bounce house
leave my mom leave my kids here my baby
bye bye disappeared for two days bro and
that was everything not everything
that's the difference you're the coke
[ __ ] and you check off for three days
or days gaming don't come back you
forgive it because you know you're a
cokehead
you know yeah but bad but if you do that
[ __ ] on my part maybe they were you just
didn't want to come back with their PCP
or nobody gets high leave this family
with we'd come back with smash where
they live well I was a Narcotics
Anonymous meeting there was a guy there
who stand out he was sober twenty years
and he were like his wife went shopping
and then he looked in the quarter and he
remember that he's to score
around there he just [ __ ] dropped his
bags he would hold it and went for a
little walk
he said he's gonna come back home Cho
Chang very pretty
Wow smelly like [ __ ] like pee dirty ass
[ __ ]
look Kearney and you know but bark
brusque I'll be easy he did die huh I
was just tripping like 20 years later
it's still gonna be there the same
corner she wasn't even a oh that one a
reportable yeah he did probably just
can't walk you broke buddy wants to
whatever your projects sooner or later
he'll find it bro don't care if it's
justified heroin coke is always gonna be
there that we often see guys like that
downtown who like look like they just
stayed too long so here's somewhere you
know and then all those like they're
still wearing their outfit from casual
Friday from work you know and it's like
Sunday like homeless drug addict oh
where I live in Hollywood it's the same
thing yeah you know those people yeah
heroin addicts all that heroin is sold
beach before dude like the everything is
so downtown before dude there's nobody
selling heroin at night it's all happens
in the morning that's all you see you
see both little guys sleepy they have to
go there but yeah they were just
chilling when you that place narcotics
are anonymous
Anonymous meetings that guy was selling
on the corner nearby right yeah Echo
Park or Silver Lake right
right outside there's like a brilliant
businessman of course you know not how
horrible human being all the best
business people are not that are the
worst kinds of people money first
there's no [ __ ] dirty KFC on a corner
where I live and there's like a Thai
restaurant and a dirty bakery just left
vertical for the outsiders dirty and
it'll dirty ass something else but in
the middle a dirty ass CrossFit to cross
Attis locations all the time yeah why do
they they're putting Crossett sand like
someone's abandoned garage and expect to
come here commando people [ __ ] and like
their heirlooms and they just put these
tires rope out of here yeah you ever
think that was gonna push the forklift
out of here jump over these box rocks
I was started you uh exercise a business
and become movie bro no one works out
like that CrossFit about houses car
washing my clothes my [ __ ] [ __ ]
clothes rock music yeah they're so angry
too like some people we bake that I call
grandma face oh I get my I get a grandma
workout face it's like half constipation
half like you know your grandparent it's
weird
I'd like to get MIT face for this thing
I saw the body wear besides out I'll
watch it love the cooking show should I
be running or cookie dough Christmas
baked you know you how do we make a
holiday bake-off bro can't miss a [ __ ]
you been to a kitty
man I like watching how did they bake
off and I like watching the Great
British Bake Off yeah I haven't seen
either of those but I know like they're
super popular
I just think about please I get angry
cuz I can't eat the food so it's like
it's like a tease to me you know what I
mean yeah I just like the way the
British
he just doesn't like the food criticizes
oh my gosh it's so perfectly she's won
the British Bake Off no it's crumbling
right sure the Rob Rob British bad teeth
too and as you gonna did about the like
there any tarts that quite the time
right she's like she's like this this
isn't up to your standards is it like
Simon Cowell yeah they make you judge
yourself it's always tough because a lot
of British British ladies they're
British guys that what East India woman
I'll try harder a lot of that going on
this is more like buck level I feel like
British people they just get away with
racism because they sound so polite
while they see yeah I mean you like want
them to continue talking little white
people right we invented a language
that's fast you get better force yeah
we're better for the day was I watching
battery Bertinelli bro oh hell yeah the
real cookie show i watch you know
watching it off a avoid wow yeah but
this is all the stuff she wanted to do
if anybody Haley was sober II like she
was [ __ ] this is the [ __ ] cake a
water break Eddie this is the part where
[ __ ] Eddie threw up on I was just
thinking about all the stuff that any
bad hated day that was really bad around
her now she the cookie so bro didn't I
heard that food was just playing guitar
on a dog
hell yeah man I'm gonna make a cake yeah
[Music]
yeah but I was so popular [ __ ] all those
people yeah there's a lot of three times
live when he did his solo stuff but
David Lee Roth's a whole other person
now and that you know no I met him once
at the Laugh Factory after a show and he
was there and I was always a little he
was sitting down oh but he was sitting
down but he was this is the moment like
I used to have posters I kind of dreamed
that like he I was gonna marry this guy
all right but you know what to draw down
I was thinking about like like she's
walking up boom going yeah you know
maybe he's gonna ask me on a date when
you're a kid right oh yeah but uh
so I meet him and this was just what so
I met him around then so I'm much older
at that point so but I shook his dreams
our dreams I he couldn't have been more
full of Jack Daniel's at the time was he
nice like he was nice but he looked
right through me and I was just a sloth
I was shaking his hand I was like man
you're not supposed to be your heroes
never be here I was so disappointing and
I don't care about any famous people
I've met a lot of famous people except
for David man David yeah yeah take this
thing for the first time what you're my
favorite idol you know what I get some
crack that's exactly no but I'm sure
that conversation wasn't a product of a
rape oh man that wouldn't be on the map
we've seen that [ __ ] documentary I was
walking around when I was like really
bad weed crack right there by the river
mm-hmm how's everything over at dancing
and so car pulled over and he goes hey
Philippe your party ran and he pulled
over in style you got the car we're
going bad I'm just looking around for
somebody I want you to I'm trying to get
some crack man disguised I see I don't
like those memories dawg now I could
about you but it like when somebody
tells you a memory you can't remember
you're like what the [ __ ] yeah I don't
like my childhood type [ __ ] I wasn't
even on drugs I just blocked it out
that's good to me yeah I'm like no doubt
that must have been somebody else you
got confused yeah but there are so many
times when you remember people or
stories and things that happened when
you were totally loaded and that's what
surprises me and you're like oh no
you're that guy thinking brain teasers
yeah like his he selects he selectively
forgets it yeah it's part of the
manipulator because life's become days
and weeks
I remember partying at the Casa latina
mm-hmm there's a comedy show that was
every Tuesday nights
Jorge Perez Jeff Garcia
Rafi made you know even JB smooth and
will pay like $100 to do fits in balance
goes Tuesday nights he was 18 and over
but it was packed I'm talking about
packed all Latinos all Mexicans 250 200
people these are the people huh nah more
about 200 200 Tuesday night and that
dancing laughter and all the Mexican
shows have dancing after common mother
yeah it was like it's a party beer it
had tacos and it was a playable darkest
parts of Rosemead like those doors are
being under the freeway it was dark now
you could take a girl to your friends of
your friends monterrico back with a coat
nobody noticed
oh my neck me yeah I wonder why you call
that guy there was so much there was I'm
sorry there was someone like I do those
productivity not there but these people
were like it realize it was during the
real estate heyday man everybody there
have money right and but at what point
but no nothing you were just talking
about these shows on Tuesday nights cuz
of Athena yeah
selectively remembering oh yeah partner
week selectively so I finished the show
and I wouldn't party now was subdued and
then he told me about some other party
that's all right let's go so I was
drugged we get to that party and it was
like calm
cocido bro like the era of three
blackjack tables going like an
underground underground yeah there a gap
in the house oh it's like a warehouse I
know they had a refrigerator like the
commercials bro full of Corona and
everybody was gambling those drugs
everywhere bro like a little dish after
hours and after hours yeah what who
books that I still go to 11:30 dude
the next day yeah and I was think of
people I don't even know bro but I guess
later on that paste owes it to a place
where they where they sells out of bath
I can't because people are coming in by
bricks dude and then when I left I got
gave me a little chunk here's a little
piece man maybe if he goes to help you
off of that so day if he gave me like a
little yeah that'll help you like I eat
I eat the best but I'll doing coke that
night so I just took it to my friend's
house because he likes to eat it so I
trade it I trade half of it for coke and
I did the rest and I remember that night
became a week because I did that I did
that line bro and it burned by those
like yeah I felt like one of those
monsters bro from fro [ __ ] bad max
the do one one that was freaky don't
don't whatever the [ __ ] they were
shrieking I thought I was I've never
done cocaine I know it's weird news I'm
from Vegas but like I went back to Vegas
last weekend and it was like 10 a.m. and
all all the people I was with were just
like busing it out like as if it's like
you know part of their breakfast uh-huh
and they looked at me looking at them
they're like oh I'm sorry I'm like I'm
not judging you I I did adderall as a
kid at you know at 5 you know it gets
fine I'm it just Vegas brings that out
of you come on in for Hollywood you guys
do it all the time delivery people yeah
I mean I don't know I like we'd better
what do you talk about weed weed when I
was 19 I started running anything to put
there I stopped for ten years you just
didn't smoke for ten years at all what
did everything you oh you got so far you
were 20
yeah but now you smoke weed yeah the
first time I smoked weed I remember
never meet my friend Bobo
Oscar Jaramillo and Rafa Murad and this
holiday baccala but cooler being beads a
vaccine Oh so accident you know we get a
vaccination shot it's what your skills
was up is that what he looked like those
do they get a bunch of thousand of them
so it illegally should be back seed
though well it was about Kuna though
he's no it was like a bunch of like
measle shots real there that fool gets
angry no she loves it at you oh my god
he like arrow James almost so uh so what
chillin bro it out the first time you
ever smoke well I would have to
Christmas party I didn't even have a
[ __ ] job but these guys had jobs
right after high school I was a loser
bro but they invited me to a Christmas
party I never been to a Christmas party
off for a job I don't know how to act
I was nervous bro I was like I was not
nervous but I thought she was gonna pop
out had a knife and everything for your
work Christmas party I don't know he
said the total backwards would I don't
know telling everybody to her do you
have a nose for not happening people
just take a knife bro yeah for
protection
I don't you know bro [ __ ] that it wasn't
those you don't know those fools dawg
and what if you get large homes don't
keep telling me he keep prepping me I
was talking to a guy who started to
another guy who had never been to any to
anything out of the projects poison
advice Christmas party yeah where people
with a boss you got to be careful out
there
exactly
hey hold me down hold me you just
[ __ ] you might be a set of hopes
yeah so that fool gave you a dice roll
to take to the party though
Rambo [ __ ] right here it's funny cuz
every time that'll be a load I have my
pocket ready like like what work funny
because we [ __ ] in the party sometimes
then you're on edge like Oh a looper
we're not sure what a rabbit right yeah
like if you don't know who's gonna be
there you've got your eyes on everybody
just stare that like you know you're
looking for who's you know cool my
friends with who's my enemy here you
know but that one party we went to that
was just a totally normal party after
your movie you did back in 2009 right
and he goes man this is a first part he
didn't know anybody there really except
the camera guy that was on the movie and
he invited him he goes man is the first
party I've ever been to where I didn't
want to cheap shot somebody so I think
of that party outside the porch like
like David Friday after day David and
then my friend was he was a little joy
never smoked never smoked before it
before so that's when we rolled it up I
smoked that [ __ ] dog clear table
laughing my first time amazing
suppose the next day the day after that
what I ate I even know what weed was
like I had it inspected or they like
nickels and dimes I don't know what it
was I just know I guess I don't know how
much money I gave up we gave you yeah
because it didn't start coming out till
I green bud probably like $60 for a
whole hour no half an ounce or a quarter
I don't know what it was but it was good
weed right there it was good weed back
there I was selling 1990 that sounds
better
so yeah I don't know and green bud quit
a south-of-the-border yeah we did 18
quarters but then I'll just go to the
give me a name
yeah then I moved to New York in 95 very
high that's when dr. Hayes P Hayes was
going around town and we have you had
the beeper number you could call and
they would come just like in big
half-baked damn and people saw that they
were like oh my god there's delivery
services like oh my god you'd never
heard of that before so people come to
your house and they'd open up the whole
thing and give you the selection and
that's where I had my bubble gun that I
can't find anymore time ago I took by
Weezer Berger at high school school to
go with his dad that's where he waited
for him
you used to bike weed from a kid who was
in high school that's hilarious
that was ridiculous bro over here he
would have cameras to see who was to see
was copy but if where's Bob I don't even
have an ounce of butter at one time yeah
they left the word how to beat his ass
that's hilarious
I heard you right you know you're so
have no weed right now bad it was funny
because I will go to their house and
they're like wow dude I've been away
from my weed he's like his brother and a
bugbear story
yeah and he's doing homework and he's
weighing it out and he gives us the aid
and he waits you don't like really want
to smoke about - I wouldn't do that you
deal with that where you have to smoke
out your dealer there's different types
of dealers like there's the one that
just wants to like have you come out to
the car they roll down the window just
this big they like drop the bag out the
window then you have the one that just
comes and just like doesn't leave he
wants to be your friend - that's why he
became a dealer because he wants to make
friends another bar gene oh no and yeah
and then you're just like Kay well I'm
gonna go now you know like you can't get
him to weave but most dealers that are
like Matt gas dealer just pop out of a
fat ass joint or a fastball right they
have a little cheap-ass little fools
with nothing I used to buy from this guy
who he would come over to my house and
drop off the weed and then he would sit
there like expected right to bust it out
and I didn't know this etiquette but I
didn't look like
you owe me right come on would you wave
a little shoulder room oh yeah
especially when I was alone like that
like know it like a server doesn't drop
off the food and then just sit there you
defeated my bike transaction if you want
to pad the amount yeah yeah if you're
gonna roll fat out of joint I don't
wanna buy exactly because then that's
gonna be something that pinches the sack
you're gonna get three point three or
scale well now living in Echo Park order
a pizza for from two boots and there's
little gangster girl showed up and she
bought the pizza she gave it to me and
she looked over by a view she was there
homey it was good disrespect but this is
the kind of porch I like to come back a
little rod and smoke up blood she called
it her what is it so bye we party I have
about the delivery guy I have I have had
a guy drop off some food for his tip I
was like sorry I don't have money to
give you but there's a boy little boy
yeah you have yeah lift I just know you
have it like you already you uh you just
they come to your house and deliver a
pizza and [ __ ] yeah well you delivering
pizza looked over there with some DVDs
like my mall pick a DVD they always
c-3po sounds like food smells good you
know
you look whatever they get some other
guy painting them right have you seen
those people that come out of their
house they don't let no one in their
house they come on closed door yeah and
they get everything right they don't
even let nobody in their pad angry yeah
others don't they just throw thing over
it's funny but that's the kind of job
that if the guy's angry about your box
but at nighttime it's not the official
like totally free like ups those guys
yes the comic we don't it's people who
have this this job delivery really like
for Amazon like oh they just like the
same day you know it's like uber for
packages yes exactly
he delivers whatever he doesn't eat
something does uber and lyft and all
this hilarious it was the best way to
get rid of old clothes I know true old
our stuff out of your house you put in a
bizarre box in your house I put my dog
poo in there now I mean you walk outside
around the first month in LA and you you
can get an entire like living room set
you know what I mean you can furnish
your home I'll do it right over like
there's some neighborhoods when you get
some good stuff oh my god really nice
stuff only a little bit of bug bugs to
like not a problem
a pregnant rose yeah no new know what
happened own living adult tell me where
I took that big ass ecology but I didn't
have [ __ ] in there we inspected it
though yeah it did not better Jairo
jingle exterminator yeah you are nothing
yeah but yeah nothing was like - yeah
you have to see that [ __ ] that's where
it happens dude hey glances that's funny
we don't live in the Lord let's throw
each other I would wake up with bites
bro oh they have a spider buyers whole
apartment was infested there you go the
place is gross the oil stone would give
me the devil that look like a place that
they vacuumed and then they painted it
with enamel thing how did you guys laugh
at you really I was freshly divorced
almost divorced
what was his line no line I really I
approached him I think like all the
ladies do I'm sorry what was your line
so that bones your line because I was
gonna put this I was gonna put this in a
scene in so that one mom thing I was
writing but anyway that's gonna be a
tough job dude but no I didn't know what
that meant
Oh how are you how white it's there's
been there was a gap in my street
knowledge okay because I had been
married for 13 years him just had a baby
and my life was all different I was
working in the corporate world
it was a mob group before she was gangs
I hadn't smoked weed in a long time
because red herring you my dad and I
used to smoke weed all the time all the
time you know so that was like but that
was the last time was before Isaac
really a long time before Isaac was born
in like probably five years so I was not
what how do you call it what do you say
I don't know I just never heard blaze
before like you know how this guy used
to treat his tab for that this I know or
he calls it the pot can I have some of
the pot I'm like roaches you guys got
the reefer yeah hey buddy you got some
reefer see someone that died with my
[ __ ] or he's gonna or he's a cop
if you call it marijuana or pot I'm
gonna question it who sent you who said
you what's the best we ever smoked like
you could just say like okay this [ __ ]
was good compared to the last time I was
that oh man I smoked a lot of good weed
I don't know I feel like I love the
jungle boys do you ever smoke any of
their stuff they end up so they have a
dispensary downtown and they have like
purple punch this one strain that I'm
like wow this is amazing it's beautiful
it's like lavender purple flat purple me
it cooked back in the days when they had
the cush Mart and Hollywood to smoke to
Matt oh gee yeah oh jeez our great I
like jiva me too because I all you bring
out on the 13th but it's so something
else well it's I mean heavy like
fulfilling like completely fulfilling I
like oh jeez because they're good for
anti-anxiety good for pain some people
only like smoking those at night but
I'll smoke them during the day that's
why I'm like so chill how about you oh
geez oh well the bomb is we die puffed
in the
like three months there's some Jack
Herer but homeboy couldn't get ahold of
it yet again really I just like Louie is
really really really really yeah but the
bomb is stuff I ever smoked back home
they came from Canada again a guy that
would only get like probably a couple
pounds of it and when that shit's gone
never got the strain again so we was up
around for about six months people were
surprised you like you were doing a show
out of town you whoa this without doing
good here well I went up to Canada like
a couple of weeks ago and it was right
after they legalized up there and I was
all nervous I wasn't gonna be able to
get weak cuz you know the lines out when
they legalized it here we're just around
the corner so I had a one of my
followers sent me a message and was like
yo if you want weed and don't want to
you know wait the dispensaries I got you
and I was like yeah this seems kind of
sketch but meet me outside of the club
in like a half hour and he rolled up
with some really good grown weed not in
the dispensaries and I was like it's all
right out here it's a little scarier
being a woman knowing anything that
invitation that being a guy in accepting
oh you know I'm fully known I was like
that's I could I could disappear this
way still a great story you know she was
gone like a eighth of the night exactly
we don't have that I mean sometimes you
do have that thought like people bring
you in don't mess people you know like
you're not so you you have a little bit
of a screening system so yeah they give
us something ridiculous like Athiya was
sad I was there up north they gave us a
long joint this long you know full of
oil okay full of oil and jugs of of dabs
all around and it was kind of a waste
yeah all the ways right yeah but it
wasn't the bomb you have to put all that
stuff in it makes me question the
quality of the flower so we would like
ours mad dusty but of the weed was like
whatever but but I felt like we should
have just cut everything gone and used
that oil for some hours and just threw
the weed away but now but we clean it up
we were burning our fingers melting all
over the place
and how about you like as far as
everybody that brings bud or
around like on the road what would you
say the bomb is [ __ ] is or on a
percentage was well this guy uh enabled
Naples that do yeah that was the old guy
out of everybody that had bomb we'd in
that one time again California it was
good for the Betty ever smoked in
Florida yeah
and that fool gave me like two grams or
Hawaii then I stayed a band just booked
it alright that way it's so good I used
to smoke a lot of weed in Florida when I
would there it's super illegal then know
it's like medical I think I think there
was somebody with a bad way to go yeah
I've turned down like I'm like I'll just
stick with what I got but thank you you
know what I mean you think there's a lot
of people out there was [ __ ] weed
now that's all popular everybody's doing
it it's like you know I feel like it's a
grower now well I mean I don't know I
feel like like legal weed is kind of
like changed things for the industry
like you know you used to be able to
walk into a dispensary and anyone could
just drop off like anyone if you're
friends with the owner you get their
product in right house like any yeah
there would be backs giant bags that you
remember they would like deal out of
like jars you know yeah and now it's all
prepackaged before it hits the shelves
but there's still like illegal
dispensaries and like deliveries out
there where it's just like old school
you walk in they have giant jars and
it's like strains that you won't see in
the shops so I mean I think it's all
kind of like we we sacrifice when we
voted for it these are the thing I think
you should've stayed the other way I
kind of do too you know but I don't know
I think it'll get better
just later on down the road one of the
once the laws relax maybe a little bit I
don't know a strong water yeah there was
70 milligrams well the thing that we
what we give what we get in return for
sacrificing all of you know the good
parts of it I guess as we know that
whatever we're getting is clean I guess
so but who really yeah and then I mean
what is clean something that
they a chemical they allow this year
they found I'm sure that you know they
don't want it because it's also sketchy
because there's only like two testing
facility like so you know and how much
money yeah yeah cuz I think if the whole
thing if you puffer so long maybe not so
many people you can start figuring out
who has the bomb it sweetie you can buy
from
right who gives you the bro deal and
there's no more bro deals you know like
legal dispenser yeah yeah the first time
yeah there's tree rape in dude it's like
duty like $70 an eighth yeah yeah or you
just get like 3 grams for like 60 bucks
legal weed is for tourists and like rich
people you know anything like I'm just I
like I just I love I like I still
support the like legal legal it was
locally owned you know family owned man
I think if the pre rose come with a
lighter or matches already and it's pre
row really that's where they spend all
that money wow this is cool I know
exactly which brand you're talking about
I still hope they send me free weed but
I'm not gonna mention them but I yeah
work on your quality of your of your
flower you know that's where it's at
it's so true what's it like this or like
do the label you're the weed comedian I
feel like they do but if you do okay
with that I'm you know people are gonna
live for me thank you but you're like
the only female weed comic that I have
ever heard of there are a few but I mean
you just made me so is she's a big
mentor to me oh that's nice she's cool
she's amazing she's very a big advocate
for weed there's a few of us out there
but if you watched my stuff I only have
a couple weed jokes I try really not to
make it a lot about that because it's
just a part of my life it's not my whole
life you know
I have other things that I can
talk about help besides you're funny
because you are you just use a lot of
your real life in your company yeah I
think that's my fun years that's the
stuff that makes you like likeable to
everybody not just the potheads cuz you
know a little bit of your life I didn't
know that your mother was the one who
put AJ in jail yeah well the judge yes
or she was now she's not know that your
bid yeah well that yeah I mean that's
that's the challenge right especially if
I'm a new comic I'm coming up and
whatnot but like seeing all the greats
they can you can take anything that's
funny it's already been said by someone
way funnier than yes so for me my thing
is I want to talk about me in my life
people want to get to know me and that's
I think how you stand out right so thank
you for that I appreciate that
so what's it like with a mother to judge
oh man
oh I mean you said your mother judge and
your father my dad as your sister as a
district attorney and my sister is a
prosecutor yeah and then my aunt [ __ ]
cops yeah yeah no I know I mean it was
weird cuz I grew up in Vegas too so I
was like they tried to like shelter us
but like we live in the city of sin you
know you walk outside there's like
billboards of hash by the meter oh it's
so true
well that's the thing is like when I you
know they they they tried to like tell
us not to do you know when someone tells
you not to do something it makes me want
to do it even more and I'm always like
oh I'm gonna do it you know but yeah I
was I was I was an alright kid I kind of
rebelled a lot
they sent me to lockdown in Utah when I
was 17 what yeah because I was
exhibiting some some worrisome behaviors
but I mean it was it was all right you
know they were cool parents but they
were very protective of two young
daughters so you're the only one who
didn't go into law then didn't know
start at all were you pushed that way
that were your parents disappointed that
you didn't go in I mean I feel like I
was never like a super career-minded
person you know like I think it was
always an assumption people would ask me
like are you gonna grow up and go into
law like your parents and I'm
like you know know like I'm not I don't
know one who asked Hoover at seven years
old how do you respond to like what your
ten-year plan is you know what I mean
like so I just I think in in high school
and caught especially when I got to
college I tried to like make them happy
and do what they expected of me but I
was so terrible at it like I would get
fired or get kicked out or just you know
I'm just not wanted in this like
professional setting but I think it
makes sense for them that I got into
comedy because like being a lawyer is
very similar to being a comic like a
trial lawyer because you're standing in
front of a group of people telling them
a story and you want them to come on
your side yeah and you can't bomb and
oftentimes like your presentation is
what makes them decide someone else's
future you know what I mean like exactly
so I think I got a lot of skills from
them from Lake well Julie loud you know
yeah pretty year yeah I think I switched
my major one time and then I took a
class on plea bargains and I saw how I
was like the system is fun you better
have some money
exactly some classes are you know well
it I was I switched my major front
because I was a communications major and
I was like well maybe I'm gonna be a
lawyer like I I wasn't I was like I you
know maybe maybe I will do what everyone
else is talent you know and then I there
was a class in college and it was about
I I watched a movie about plea bargains
it was really just like how the system
is not in favor for people who are
arrested and don't have a lot of
resource it just it works against a lot
of like Oh goodbye Larry
and I like and for me I was like I don't
want to work for I want to work for
these people you know and I have too
much I get too attached like I had to
attach to people's stories and like I
just wouldn't be the right I don't know
exactly you have to be like kind of like
oh yeah like my sister so she can handle
it she's she's just stone cold you know
did she work in Vegas - yeah she will my
dad okay so he's the DA Clark County and
my sisters it works
in off like in the office with him which
is weird yeah we didn't wanna say about
OJ how was he remorseful
I don't think so does he apologize I
don't know about the robbery no no no I
mean hey I don't it's not that broken
man no I think I mean my mom talks you
know she's a she's really good at her
job you know and it was weird how she
got that trial because it's not weird
but they it was assigned to her right
but a lot of judges really wanted to
case obviously so she got it and she
picked a jury for OJ in two weeks I mean
that's crazy
that's quick everyone knows you OJ is
you know SNL did a spoof on it about
picking the jury selection and they had
like an alien a guy that was in a coma
for like 30 years a caveman just like
and they all know who OJ was you know so
it's great it's it was a crazy crazy
situation what's up fool what's your
email my email you want my social media
yeah you can follow me at Wolfie comedy
or at Wolfie memes Facebook Twitter and
Instagram
oh you guys shows coming up we doing
viva los jokes the 11th of December the
11th yeah how's that going
so ruler so right yeah but that's the
one that it's always Pat right we have
our food there right yeah yeah yeah
built our restaurant with other one but
this one's that suck-up thing that's
kept it I have a plaque of Riverside
fool why well we we bought a brick in
the Cesar Chavez Memorial there oh
that's awesome I'd be seeing that
memorial it's in there yeah but in that
cobblestone street or whatever they have
like the kids are following him that
runs milky bars oh right it says
Felipe's world and I think it says your
name right yeah I'm gonna go smoke a
joint man you should take a selfie and
we wanted to add what's up fool they
said that was inappropriate so did my
Spanish set my seconds better said
[ __ ] how does the humor translate oh
you know what I get away with words
badly they're doing English I love that
you know you're right there there are
fewer social justice warriors in Spanish
yeah I love that I want to do my son
Spanish once I get Floyd and I I'm good
like this take a time over out I thought
I'd play with the armies of Spanish
laughs that's awesome cuz that you're
more relaxed up there now I was like
telling these two bald guys it's badly
that they both look alike no I said yes
it's the same in the same eyebrows and
it was funny because they close a board
of the next day so half of those
comedians were from Mexico really only
three only three of us were from America
yeah shut up fool Jack Botti and Gloria
and they do the glasses of a guy Benji
Benji Martin load rule Louise who puts
the show together Louisa Marta Rizal
kill in Spanish never done it I've never
gone up Wow
I bet he's used to talking to his mom
though are you are you know fluid no
well he was born in Mexico but he's got
a lot of slang and how do you even get
you here watch a lot of television like
how do you pick it up so you become
fluent the way to a show you listen to
you don't watch the any TV or you just
listen to it
yeah listen and I have other podcast
Spanish podcast
helps with some of them okay
I took Spanish my whole life and I can I
can understand it I can speak it a
little bit but not as well as I can
understand it but I really want to be
fluent yeah I can read it better than I
I feel more comfortable reading yeah and
speaking like especially theater
speakers like your mom I just I shut up
I do before I die I want to be fluent in
Spanish in my dreams I'm fluent yeah
dream dream in Spanish I have had dreams
perfectly you dream in German at the
jury glass for a whole year you can do
it perfectly in your dream right yeah
awesome
you can speak German fluently especially
toys good I said I don't speak German
very well it sounded great
you speak but you always learn a little
bit of a new language
expressions speak Deutsch good I learned
how to how to say equally worthy to this
woman at the nursing home I love you in
German but in I said I learned how to
say it because she was such a sweet old
lady at the nursing home I worked at and
I wanted to like you know thank her for
being so nice and everything she was
equally belief sounds like I know it
doesn't disgusting Gerber's don't throw
it as often as Americans no they don't
they I love you all the time I love you
we could say I love you as aggressive
let you think oh yeah I know I like tell
my bird driver I'm like you got me here
safely you love you they throw it around
in America early gee bro what's up with
them he's documented now huh yo tambien
so Kabini color another comedian that we
don't like we both know and it was like
all the emails what's your location
everything he called him out she called
him out oh because he was like it was
like he was trying to hit her up yeah
expose
yeah she's finally exposed him he's a
creepy comic that's what I'm told bro he
named his meltdown in that context
conversation with her another meltdown
aggressive honor yes Mabel
oh yeah it's no angry don't like it on
you and you will tell them respectfully
have a boyfriend or a No thank you feel
like I wasn't trying to sleep with you I
just wanted to get to know you okay -
good for me oh yeah I I didn't mean it
like that but you just said that because
it came up right what's it express it
with a woman who's big there and she
said the exactly the same thing bang
like they're like they don't know how
they can don't know how to take a
rejection or don't get lazy [ __ ] the
eternal [ __ ] off ha right I didn't watch
your ugly ass anyways you just asked me
out on a date like they'll go from zero
to 60 in no time and you know as a kid
as a girl growing up my mom was always
telling me you have to be nice while
you're rejecting a guy you have to be
like you have to worry you objectively
rough you have to worry about his ego
it's wrong letting him down when you
know if an ugly girl you know approached
a guy he'd just said you got a breakup
you got yeah exactly when you reject
when guys reject us we you know we're
fine we just cry about it in our first
of all let me go get rejected you just
don't notice that he see another JK yeah
let's see looks like Brad Pitt he ain't
get no me too on ya both people thank
you harass their creepy good I think I
think some dudes probably yeah they get
harassed by probably other dudes a girl
no I had job where guys do that
Oh each other to the guy but if you're
not into that you go straight to oh hey
char
you have every right you know the human
resource was daddy we don't you get a
job you walk into a whole world you kind
of go with the rhythm and if you don't
[ __ ] with them the main gonna [ __ ] with
you or you're gonna get a fight or
there's gonna be a standoff or don't
[ __ ] with that guy cuz it needs to be
any problems I stopped my first job was
a job who got me highway star to help
you bro or three somebody else who I
pull off the desk you take bikes are
like you know [ __ ] but it's like it
makes it to your Mexico right now that's
why that serial ababa
each time over always picks up the
character Hopi the guy's ass they did
the Dominicans would slap each other
with the towels with the bar tells you
know especially if I do come out of the
kitchen with like a 6 feet or 4 feet
sausage he'll slap somebody face dude
can't hold a sausage without doing
girl right those titties you know take a
shaded little rock go for what will your
holy ghost opportunist mother I brought
up be a video bad do the hell with that
video I don't I can't explain the video
that's why I've watched it so [ __ ]
much at one time that's it once I was
two girls one carping know it's this
thing that was going around last week in
is lady there okay then he smells it but
like sometimes I get front wedgies so I
can get I can understand no looking
forward but apologies for what the
stakeout video did I've never seen I
didn't know what to expect like where's
this is bizarre he digs in there bro
like they put her faith oh yeah like
he's putting some what the prisoner
going to hold for the Gestapo yeah
they're going into those are the same
people that are taking the salad bar
with their own hands I've seen it
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
because I've seen people I've seen
there's this one comic on my timeline he
posed like I've seen people that people
have like sex in public at bus state
stops like they're literally having sex
at a bus stop and I'm like really
[ __ ] froggy
shuttle frog bro for San Diego is moving
up to the fight of the Final Four where
else of comedy card to the San Diego at
the madhouse the bad house
congratulations bro thanks man let's do
comedy clothes gonna be in the same
street which one madhouse American comic
living in the middle opening up The
Laugh Factory
what they're opening one up in San Diego
yeah might be like a little hooded
hundred cedar that the mini Gotham's I
love it super in them in our floor I saw
Michael Rapaport yesterday oh hell yeah
how was that oh my god he came sure I
was like four friends and I didn't get a
chance to say hello but he he texted me
so she saved a fan so that he was doing
stand-up the Joe Rogan showed up bro
powerhouse it was funny man and just
just yeah just the way was cool I met
some guy from Mississippi named Eric
Carter I saw George Perez
I saw his who's Trejo Eric
Eric Griffin what's up he's great and
fun if he saw thought together right it
was honest and then like these food that
look like cholos he was what is the
Mexican hipster snob wrote just a bunch
of chip stirs yeah I was there last
night I must have missed you yeah
because I saw all those people you did
yeah I probably just missed your set you
see they both tell bro was there yeah
Jeffrey Peters a rock Jeffrey Ross the
roastmaster general enjoyed cocoa cocoa
that's right [ __ ] I would live
for a little while cause I've been part
of you for a while and I noticed that I
wear that Michelle wolf yeah of course
positive people attack your ass
what what people attack at you Oh when
she did hurt with a course on his dinner
uh no I mean they I didn't really they
didn't really mix us up because we look
nothing on we also sound nothing like
but no I mean not really cuz there's
also like a Josh wolf
I don't him yeah but I did yeah Kevin
called me Michelle onstage last night
but like I mean it doesn't happen that
often we look nothing like thank
goodness because then it would be
confusing not that no because she's
great crazy bad they just twist anybody
named wolf oh well there's yeah you I
mean you seen this stuff that goes on
Twitter we like hate tweet people like
hate tweet the wrong person and it goes
viral
I let the funny was like would you look
at memes from other nationalities like
you have no idea what what the reference
is but you try to figure it out
let Dominicans like I said it was a BB I
said when you're Dominican with the
billikin say they ain't black but but
then they showed the Medicaid
grandmother it is a dad from good times
yeah yeah shows coming up I'm in Vegas
tomorrow and Friday I'm at um bonkers
and then I'm at the Hooters because you
know the hilarious seven yeah that one
and there no no I'm not headlining and
then I have a I'm featuring in Brea
tonight 27 to 30 27 through 30 hanging
out with you guys oh you will be taro
and probably won't do it let's do it I
would love to you it'll be me you see
the Estrada Chris Estrada what the [ __ ]
Chris Estrada you feel me I'm in let's
do it I'm Joey I'm probably the second
show on Sunday we're gonna do one
Thursday to Friday to Saturday to Sunday
we just added a second because it's all
sold out except Thursday and now this
second Sunday show yeah
and I believe the back there believe it
or certainly - Oh beautiful
are you around New Year's Eve do you
want to do the show in Denver how's the
weed out in Denver that's all right week
a lot of people say it's all badass cuz
it went legal and shits all right like
you said man you know the weed the best
we still the people who don't have our
license yourself yeah for sure
I agree that the Louie bro oh yeah man
but Louis the 13 have pre-roll that's
Bob like that's one of the best pre rows
out there and those cookie was again
yeah I know that well that jar it tells
you the potency it tells you where was
it made when they harvest it stuff yeah
it tells you best the best munch used to
eat it like a it let they cut off all
the other jargon the pot dealer will
tell you you know like you know that she
need to be grilled yeah since the media
right know that it's it's a it's like
the health information which farm it
came from how many hands touched it how
high you're gonna get
it's the future what the biggest show
you've done Oh like biggest in size like
how many people yeah probably one of the
improv shows that like one of the big
rooms or Oxnard or yeah probably one of
those would you perform in Canada uh
Calgary and Edmonton one at one of the
clubs I already forgot because it's been
a couple weeks ago and I smoked a lot
since then and then two or their three
shows were at like what are they called
performance spaces venues you were done
that pot show in Toronto which one after
Charlie Toshiro Baba I haven't done that
one I do the Gateway I have I've done
the Gateway show have you done that one
no that's my friend Billy Anderson he
puts on a show where you do 10 minutes
sober and then you come back it really
high and do 10 minutes really high [ __ ]
the whole 20 hi well he tells he's like
you can't smoke during the day I'm like
this is the hardest part is like being
sick it was ruled by - all right do you
timber how do they take you to it the
way to hit you 10 minutes to hit me real
good what it's gonna hit me the peak
broad 10 50 minutes yeah but you're he
he may give everyone leave for an
intermission for 15 minutes and you just
get as high as possible edibles blunts
joints drinks whatever hits at that
point they have it here I'll say I'll
tell I'll send you the info you should
do it that's good chef dabs include that
you can bring dad's he had he has
sponsors so he man maybe they took it
down maybe the couple like found out got
there like what are you doing putting
our moves on here couple put his head in
ass oh my god 17,000 videos pop up did
you mean yeah a lot of them so up but
not the one
either way in parking lot okay there you
go
yeah for good luck what about is the
input can you pull it up here no cuz she
search on that tablet though no brother
all just weird was now now it's just
porn now it's just an entire selection
on pornhub not a bunch of chicks part of
me yet how'd you guys find it I saw it
on Facebook I thought like someone was
like it was crazy but they just look
like normal people who are about to
return the shopping cart back after they
used it which I like I saw this V I'm
like oh look at these citizens returning
the car and then you just hand goes in
I'm like are there standing up yeah
they're just there they're in the
parking lot returning their shopping
cart and the husband I'm assuming that's
her husband or her brother or son looks
like a couple that could be waiting in
line in private or chillin in the car
oh they told me them ah so what cuz I
was like dude how crazy is like right
behind them like wow that's something
you can't unsee yeah I don't know if you
want to see it I was disturbed by it
it's inequitable it doesn't make any
sense why would you want a [ __ ] smell
like he put it he put his head out there
maybe she's part on it they put her I
swear this this is a there is a
selection on pornhub for this type of oh
yeah coming up people feel oh oh here we
go coming up people Tempe Arizona next
week December 7 through 9 with the
hilarious well Gina Torres and the
hilarious Martin Rizzo Marta Rizzo and
even more hilarious Chuck Martel
George Washington
Minneapolis is for tomorrow sweetie so
fun
he's so funny he'll bring the umbrella
I'll Terrell California December 27th
through 30th
our general improv you already heard you
right here we have our duo Torres we got
Chris Estrada
what is course Caesars Chris Caesar
makes a good shoulder community okay
good okay
jumping house okay Rachel Wulff he said
Wolfson Deborah Colorado December 30 40
years a part of our theater Bridgeport
Connecticut January third to the fourth
stress factory Turlock January 26
together going fast they are going very
fast for that Turlock show so you better
hurry Lisa made a barback things give it
was all vegan vegan Thanksgiving yeah
Tofurky seventh she made a bomb as the
back of cheese do she put the cheese in
the blender with hot I'm coming next
year bringing the green oh yeah do you
guys have mashed potatoes okay there
were no mashed potatoes at my
Thanksgiving am never coming what
happened oh that's the reason that other
person showed up what time did they have
a have he lost it oh yeah my way but by
our brothers sisters our daughters wife
okay so the [ __ ] was that which is
that's they make like a turkey she had
cynics she gets a pass it's like a sorry
a a stewed turkey sandwich that's like
dripping and gravy it's like a it's like
a remix on Thanksgiving yeah but it's
like a Salvadorian American well not
just America South America Salvadorians
do it over I would Salvadorans yeah why
would any other country because you have
fights if you posted up about
Thanksgiving or Christmas and the other
people have like no we only do that for
Thanksgiving or no I only do it for
Christmas and then everybody starts
fighting it we killed Oh rose we're
gonna do our own thing he was like he
was late so he didn't he missed the
whole speech that was given about the
sandwiches in the beginning of this he
was like what the he goes what no we
didn't have ham on Christmas we didn't
have there's no Turkey to hear this no
ham
he was so what was a speech about the
sandwich it was just like the story
behind the tradition behind it was all
we had at the we just put it into a
sandwich back in the days 13 marketing
there's a guy to caravan to cover we
just helped him with his branding what I
did my job last night brought about how
they were pepper sprayed the caravan
he'll come on man he can't scare about
you know with pepper spray ran the child
do that over here around we just put my
taco are they good hilarious so true
what's up boo but you know what man but
there were sprayed those people
everybody were putting out videos when
President Obama was spraying them too
but they're like oh I was gonna get into
it but I wanna right so you're saying
that he was tough on immigration now or
what are you telling me here are you
saying it now because it fits your
narrative but but but Obama kicked a lot
of fools bro dude
have a friend that works for ice that
was born in Tijuana and that's all he
does all day overtime there's snatcher
fools but he snatches like child
molesters murderers and [ __ ] like that
not like [ __ ] average people now even
going back there for shoplifting
a buddy that he was working just as hard
as when I was a bomber was in is with
this fool it was a lot of Russia Russian
army - hiding - huh well yeah people
forget about all that we do like a lot
of people they busted a house in
Monterey Park right there that like they
bring the ladies from China to give
birth there yeah oh wow yeah so they
have kids here yeah like there's like a
whole trade on that and some of them
like come on locked up in like big old
drums crazy poor ages so dramatic
everybody has a rich people do you can't
marry hit my daughter because your
dishwasher it'll be a super high if you
realize why they cost super Super Mario
Brothers Super Mario Brothers why either
super super that was a book being the
super right yeah PJs I thought they were
plumbers back in the day where they had
like you know I don't know if they still
have a regular super anymore you know
you should have a more in like apartment
complex or the Mexican job be a
technical technical said we sell it
daughter was another world your super by
the way if anybody
every day of my life yeah yeah I think I
do I think if I if I hear the words I
could tell why I persuaded my son it's a
great show great holds up so yeah that
was it thanks for having me so let's go
how did we know carbon